[Musique]
et nous voici dans le salon doré votre
bureau désormais monsieur le président à
ça tu as trop bien c'est beaucoup plus
grande chambre
le général fut le premier à l'occupant
dans la chasse ça va pas du tout par
contre faudra mettre des roulettes monde
à mettre une chaise de gamer alors en
tant que chef du protocole et au nom de
toute l'équipe de l'elysée nous sommes
heureux d'accueillir le plus jeune
président de la république jamais ouais
ça c'est parce qu'ils ont changé le
système de vote comme ça se fait en
ligne maintenant ma commune qu elles
étaient à fond je veux pas de programme
mais alors nous avons un certain nombre
de poids à voir ensemble à commencer par
la valise nucléaire en tant que chef des
armées vais prendre connaissance du code
de tir une dame en personne d'autres que
vous ne doit connaître ce code
extrêmement confie nativement 2 37 42 37
et voici votre portrait officiel
j'espère qu'il sera votre goût c'est ma
photo ça mais ça va pas du tout ça donne
pas du tout envie de cliquer pardon de à
qui faire soi-même ici j'étais prier
toshop contourne l'angle flèche rouge
imprimés
ça c'est une bonne photo là ça
interpelle vous voulez qu'on mettre ça
dans toutes les écoles et les mairies de
choses ouais c'est votre ligne ou supris
oui sous oui ici le président de la
république
las
yes trump thank you va te trompe c'est
pas le bon numéro tu t'es trompé je vais
pas filmer mais quand je fais un truc
comme ça il faut filmer
là on a vu une vidéo de malades point
que pierre donald trump ça tourne mal 10
millions de vues facile d'havré monsieur
le président c'est ce qu'on va faire on
va faire un podcast à quoi depuis que je
suis président de la république personne
ne m'appelle cyprien c'est terminé tout
on m'appelle monsieur le président
monsieur le président tu peux m'appeler
cyprien monsieur le président je suis
pris dans cyprien tout court je suis le
ton prénom ton père mais monsieur le
préserver ces super nul à toulouse super
mal tu feras jamais le tueur ça c'est
sûr ah oui ah oui oui entrez entrez
mais ça ici au ram et essaoui qu'est ce
que c'est monsieur cette question de
produits prenez-en à naples en passant
même pas ça c'est bon je vais faire du
classement de produits à l'elysée oui
j'ai vu la dette publique sur internet
il faut bien avoir des idées là pour
rembourser tout ça bon maintenant je
suis président n'y a pas un truc que je
peux faire leur premier lieu je vais
nommer votre gouvernement non pas des
ministres que vous avez choisi enfin
j'imagine de dépenser un gouvernement
ouais ouais j'ai fait ça j'ai fait
dessus et bien sûr bien sûr j'ai un
gouvernement de la demande demande j'ai
toujours choisi notre premier ministre
squeeze norman c'est normal on prêt
ministre ministre de l'éducation docteur
norman pour la santé dans ton corps oui
bon bref j la liste inquiet parce que je
t'enverrai un mémo on va plutôt faire
une allocution
excellente idée monsieur le président
vous allez vous adresser aux français je
vais appeler les chaînes de télévision
hervé avec les chaînes de télé à quelle
époque de suivi dont on va faire un live
facebook serait bien
françaises français tout d'abord merci
de votre confiance en tant que président
de la république je pense rôle très à
coeur aussi j'ai décidé de ne pas perdre
de temps avant de mettre en place ma
première réforme
chers concitoyens
à partir d'aujourd'hui il y aura une
réduction d'impôt pour chaque français
qui sont abonnés à ma chaîne youtube
s'il ya des questions c'est sur twitter
non dubé energix